yeah hello welcome to this video aqaba
in the house sir that's a very frequent
opponent 22 games played and I don't
really remember having wide against much
I only remember that I constantly have
those scotch games against him so we
have some kind of yeah almost exchanged
Slav kind of position with g6 however
and not normally considered a great
setup on the other hand the Queen on b3
is not ideally placed and it okay be 59
so going for be five in this position
hot hard to believe well I think this
could be an interesting idea if he takes
so when you cannot take probably even d
take c5 is a move but also knight takes
Bishop takes is called from white and b5
is obviously not playable I was thinking
maybe night 85 as a move I can even go
queen before so somewhat we at square
but between a four runs in to be five
looks good
like my position I think I should be
slightly better yeah let's go for that
yeah something like rook e8 possibly
Bishop f8 maybe
even if night a4 is an idea like night a
four to be six well looks like he's he's
shooting for that so night a four or is
that too weird b5 95mm shouldn't be so
bad night on c5 we might be six is a
threat so he basically had to do that
okay hmm where are you going with that I
have knight c6 Queen doesn't have many
squares but ok it's not isn't that great
I wonder have a4 is a movie em a four a
five Queen B 5 he cannot even attack the
Queen ma'am so a form looks good
whoa really I can do many things knight
c6 for example and then take on b5 isn't
that just good all right come on let's
let's think about this for a moment this
took so terrible there should be
something directly to you however this
is gautam where is he going queen bee
697 loses loses immediately and i think
yes to go to e8 and then i'm taking b5
check g7x with including the house here
hmm you just continuously being
completely unimpressed yeah so is there
some kind of trickery don't see it don't
see it
just a piece
if I take okay this is probably the
easiest we should be one who should be
three and then bring the King into the
game should win a pretty easily k let's
do this and now see how to how to win
win this it's probably better even with
the King being on b3 well I guess so
now it anyway we cannot do much okay
let's take the eighth how now now that
he has given it to me
check no Roxy one cheek I can play at
five
yeah easeus is probably this check and
Jack go over to age 70 what is that what
is the simplest way to win f5 maybe at
five is also pretty good check I wide if
I T group t8 check on e6 ok check on you
Sixtus win check check climb were need
not to totally sure what the point is
I'm even head on time
Jeff should wear three is almost made
can I meet him somehow directly check my
ass he didn't go to g3 I thought you
would go to g3 less resign next move
yeah it was disastrous opening result
Renee I think that I don't think that
that geez six years is a good reply to
be honest see txt five should be quite
comfortable version of the of the
exchange slob Bishop one g7 is not a
good piece should be to raise 6 10 okay
this this is pretty pretty clear my 86
yeah well night a 4 interesting choice i
don't know i can go Castle sook see one
all kinds of things but this is a very
direct move Knight b6 is a substantial
threat I on the engine wants to play my
t4 and that's interesting if I do this
now oh that's a that's a very cool
defense
check and black wins yeah compute the
defense nice engine wants to go Queen B
6 cm this is the the engines line with
the slide edge too wide interesting okay
well this was played and 95 yards this
should be good for white nor a form and
white is about plus one according to the
comp computer wants to play it wants to
play the the can of the other simple
stuff like this but here why this just
permanently battered you to the a pond
that probably we will be falling that
poem I don't think black can take it I
can keep it in the long run okay this is
what he did I meant no knight c6 is just
yeah almost winning this lost everything
but he could go here and then I'll take
him this line was what i have so and our
just a pawn and a good position on top
but yet it was peace and for peace no i
think probably there was some there was
some way to improve on my technical play
but it was sufficient bring the king
into the game I was gaining a space here
and now he gave me the foul check yeah
5s is probably possible immediately but
I just wanted to make sure that I'm
check and nothing bad happens and now I
went for a five this is the thing I
cannot get this pawn and he I'm just
winning more Ponzi so it was pretty yeah
pretty clear victory I guess okay thanks
for watching